quand 6
je suis à lyon au stade des lumières
mon
qui paie moi sortons de notre vestiaire
et nous dirigeons vers le tunnel d'accès
à la pelouse
les deux équipes sont alignés derrière
le rideau qui affiche les normes logo de
l'équipe locale
j'ai froid il pleut je sens l'odeur du
feu d'artifice qui vient d'être proposé
aux 54 mille spectateurs présents les
haut parleurs relais les chants des
supporters qui s'impatientent et je
n'entends plus rien d'autre les caméras
nous film je vérifie si j'ai tout mon
matériel
la montre le sifflet les cartons
le spray ce soir je vais arbitrer le
derby entre lyon et saint-etienne et
c'est bien plus qu'un match de foot
c'est une question de suprématie
régionale voire nationale pendant cette
rencontre
je vais prendre environ 245 décision
soit une décision
toutes les 22 secondes 45 décisions sont
simples ballon sorti basique il reste
200 situation où mon leadership et ma
posture vont jouer 30 situation seront
formalisées d'un coup de sifflet ça veut
dire qu'il reste 170 décision qui ne se
voit pas et qui vont impacter la
rencontre comme pour vous la majorité de
vos décisions ne se voit pas et
impactent votre organisation arbitrer un
match de foot c'est faire face à plein
de situations complexes être dans
l'adaptabilité constante sans être
certain de prendre la bonne décision à
chaque fois dans ce monde actuel qui
mêle volatilité incertitudes complexité
ambiguïté qu on appelle un monde vu cas
je vois beaucoup de similitudes entre l'
arbitre de haut niveau et le dirigeant
bits de haut niveau et dirigeants nous
sommes d'ailleurs su soumis aux mêmes
pressions tout d'abord la concurrence
nous sommes 23 arbitres en liga chaque
décision va impacter notre classement
final à l'issue de la saison les
meilleurs deviendront internationaux ou
sur maintiennent les moins bons seront
rétrogradés si je tombe en ligue 2 je
perd 40% de la rémunération
en moins de 15 jours comme pour votre
organisation
la perte d'un gros marché peut mettre en
danger votre stratégie
il ya ensuite les nouveaux entrants ce
sont ces jeunes arbitres qui nous font
4e qui ont les dents qui rayent le
parquet qui n'ont qu'une seule envie
c'est de prendre notre place
et quand ils nous voient arbitrer ils
disent qu'ils ont largement le niveau
ces nouveaux entrants ce sont les
nouveaux managers dans vos organisations
qui n'ont qu'une seule ambition c'est de
prendre votre place et c'est là tout le
dilemme comment faire équipe avec eux
pour atteindre ses objectifs ambitieux
dans un univers sous pression il ya
ensuite les produits de substitution
c'est la vidéo dans l'arbitrage la
première fois que j'ai été appelé à
l'écran pour modifier une décision
ça m'a touché dans mon orgueil ça m'a
fait mal mais j'ai travaillé ma
perception et la vidéo c'est comme un rp
dans une entreprise ça nous sécurise
certaines décisions et ça nous permet de
nous focaliser sur notre vraie valeur
ajoutée notre leadership arrive enfin
les deux pouvoirs de négociation les
plus fort pouvoir de négociation des
clients pouvoir de négociation des
fournisseurs en tant qu'arbitre mon
client c'est la ligue du football
professionnel
il y a quelques années lors d'un stage
d'avant saison
je discute en aparté avec celui qui
était alors le directeur de la ligue du
football professionnel
franck tu es un bon arbitre tu suives 35
fautes par match tu donnes 3,9
avertissement par rencontre c'est trop
je suis en train de négocier les droits
télé il me faut plus de temps de jeu
effectif moins deux joueurs suspendus
pour valoriser le championnat ok je
pense avoir compris le message
mais quelques semaines plus tard je
rencontre le président du club local qui
m'attendent dans mon vestiaire
monsieur schneider vous sifflez 35
fautes par match
vous donnez 3,9 avertissement par an
contre ce n'est pas assez cette saison
je joue la coupe d'europe le championnat
la coupe de france et j'attends de vous
que vous protégiez mes joueurs je ne
savais plus quoi penser
comment j'allais faire parmi ses 200
situation pour savoir celle que j'allais
sanctionné d'un coup de sifflet et celle
que j'allais laisser passer je vais vous
partager mes clés arbitral pour faire de
ce monde vu qu'à une opportunité de
renforcer votre leadership
la première étape c'est la boussole ce
qu'on appelle la raison d'être
il ya énormément de choses sur
lesquelles nous n'avons pas la main mais
nous avons la main sur notre raison
d'être un arbitre au fait pourquoi est
il pour donner une vision et du sens à
ma fonction
j'ai travaillé ma raison d'être c'est un
mal nécessaire nécessaire ça veut dire
que si les joueurs pouvaient s'autogérer
je ne serais certainement pas là comme
dans vos organisations
si vos collaborateurs pouvait s'auto
gérer
certainement que vous ne seriez pas là
un mal nécessaire
ça veut dire qu'on est rarement apprécié
voir très souvent contesté mais qu'on
permet à la rencontre de se dérouler
dans les meilleures conditions
si je voulais rendre ma raison d'être un
peu plus positive
je dirais un arbitre facilitateur qui
permet à chaque joueur d'exprimer son
plein potentiel
mais un mal nécessaire me convient bien
je ne cherche pas les paillettes ni le
feu des projecteurs et cette raison
d'être me guide
même dans les rencontres est plus
difficile à prendre des décisions très
délicate
elle me motive et me rassure
après ma boussole voyons comment
j'avance j'avance avec ma griffe ma
marque de fabrique en quelque sorte la
griffe
c'est ce que les gens penseront deux
mois après un match après une saison où
après une carrière
la griffe c'est ce que les
collaborateurs penseront de vous après
la gestion de crise par exemple ma
griffe
c'est solide et juste solide
ça veut dire avoir un état émotionnel
stable quel que soit le contexte quelle
que soit la difficulté montrer qu'on va
emmener tout le monde à bon port
même quand le bateau tangue juste ça
veut dire prendre une décision juste
quel que soit le joueur quelle que soit
l'équipe solide et juste ça veut dire
garder cette justesse même quand on se
trompe et ne pas tomber dans la
compensation par exemple ça va donner
confiance aux équipes et ça va justement
nous permettre d'avancer dans les
meilleures conditions pour préparer
cette griffe et pour la renforcer
j'ai anticipé et j'ai travaillé ce qu'on
appelle les moments de vérité
ce sont des moments qui sont
particulièrement importants et impactant
dans ma fonction
la première faute sifflée la première
contestation prendre une grosse décision
alors je n'ai pas tous les éléments pour
décider comment gérer un président et un
entraîneur qui m'attendent à la sortie
du terrain quelle image j'ai envie de
renvoyer à quel moment et comment je
vais me prendre pour justement assurer
cette image ça nous amène à avoir une
démarche prospective et à anticiper tous
ces moments qui sont importants dans
notre fonction pour illustrer cela il ya
une citation que j'aime beaucoup qui est
expect the unexpected
et vous quel est votre griffe et que
faites vous pour la rendre visible
on a vu le cap
qu'on donne et on a vu comment on
avancer voyons maintenant comment cela
s'illustre sur le terrain sous pression
avec quels outils
le premier c'est l'écoutent l'écoutent
de l'environnement et ces signaux
faibles pour illustrer ce point je vais
vous dévoiler la face cachée de france
irlande un match complètement vue cas en
2009 avec la main de thierry henry fort
enjeu économique fort enjeu sportif
un arbitre dans le top 5 mondial sur la
pente ascendante
l'équipe qui marque se qualifie pour la
coupe du monde
il reste dix sept minutes à jouer
la france marque au même moment tous les
irlandais réclame une main et demande
d'annuler le but quand tous les joueurs
d'une même équipe
au même moment vous réclame une faute
c'est ce qu'on appelle un signal faible
très très fort larbitre avait l'habitude
de ce genre de crise et il avait ses
process il est donc allé voir son
assistant et lui a demandé si le buteur
avait marqué de la main l'assistant à
lui a confirmé que non et l' arbitre a
conforté sa décision et l'a validé le
but
dans ce genre de situation complexe
il est important d'être à l'écouté de
son environnement et l'information peut
venir de partout
même des joueurs à condition de les
écouter
main oui mes mains de qui pas du buteur
mais du passeur
l'arbitré aurait pu de challenger sa
première perception avancer étape par
étape
chronologiquement poser une question
ouverte aux irlandais quelles mains quel
joueur
et si un joueur est désigné
allez voir ce joueur et lui poser une
question fermée
avez-vous fait main posé des questions
plutôt que d'affirmer ça paraît simple
mais le faire sous stress avec la
pression des joueurs
la pression des caméras c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué et ça se travaille
conséquence pour l' arbitre fin de
carrière
après l' écoute voyons comment je décide
sur le terrain ce n'est pas parce qu'on
a réfléchi en équipe qu'on va décider en
équipe
notre style de leadership et la
difficulté de la situation à gérer vont
faire en sorte qu'on va choisir le mode
de décision et il est important
d'assumer ça avec son équipe au départ
la particularité de l'arbitrage c'est
quand même l'instantanéité de la
décision et ça laisse peu de place à
l'improvisation
alors je me suis amusé à conscientiser
une matrice de prise de décision comme
une entreprise en fonction de qui
détient l'information en entreprise ça
serait la personne sur site ou la
personne au siège et qui est responsable
de la décision en entreprise ça serait
le drh pour les affaires sociales par
exemple donc pour l'arbitrage
un arbitre assistant est responsable des
hors jeu s'il a vu la situation de hors
jeu ça match il aime le drapeau je
siffle c'est simple mais lors d'une
rencontre de football comme en
entreprise
il peut se passer des choses qu'on ne
voit pas dans notre dos alors oui
l'arbitré responsable des penaltys et
des cartons rouges
mais si tout le monde l'a vu sauf lui et
que son assistant lui détient
l'information et a vu la situation est
bas dans ce cas là j'ai décidé de le
laisser décider et j'assumerai cette
décision ça nous permet d'être plus
agiles
ça nous permet de garder un état
émotionnel stable et ça nous permet de
continuer à imprimer note griffe
quand on prend des décisions difficiles
et un enjeu qu'il faut également prendre
en compte celle enjeux émotionnels des
joueurs comme pour vous en entreprise
quand vous voulez faire un recadrage
c'est le oui à la personne mais le nom à
l'acte ça me rappelle un samedi après
midi au parc des princes il fait beau le
stade est plein tout le monde attend des
buts et du spectacle
avant cette rencontre
cavani était à 99 buts 14 minutes de jeu
cavani marque un but il faut savoir
qu'au football un joueur qui marque un
but et qui enlève son maillot pour fêter
ça doit être averti d'un avertissement
automatiquement
le stade est en ébullition les
partenaires font la fête avec lui
les médias sont ravis cavani se dirige
vers la tribune enlève son maillot et le
jette
comment j'allais faire pour gérer cette
situation et continuer à imprimer ma
griffe j'avais préparé ce moment de
vérité avant le match est plutôt que
d'aller vers la tribune et d'aller voir
cavani je me suis dirigé vers le banc de
touche et je les ai attendus
quand il est arrivé pour récupérer son
nouveau maillot
je lui ai tendu la main avec le sourire
et sourire c'est pas mon fort et lui m'a
serré la main avec le sourire ça ça
voulait dire bravo pour votre valeur le
oui à la personne et ensuite
je lui ai mis un avertissement et ça ça
voulait dire non au fait d'avoir enlevé
son maillot
il a accepté avec le sourire ils
savaient à quoi s'en tenir et notre
relation a été pérenne à chaque fois qu
on s'est revu ce qui aurait pu mettre en
danger ma griffe a été au contraire une
opportunité de la renforcer et d'être un
temps forts de la rencontre
il est 22 heures 55
coup de sifflet final je suis épuisé
j'ai beaucoup couru
nous rentrons au vestiaire nous
entendons le chant des supporters qui
crient à la victoire de leur équipe
ça sent la transpiration mais ça sent
surtout le travail d'équipé bien fait
grâce à notre raison d'être et grâce à
notre griffe
nous avons maintenu le cap même quand le
bateau pouvait tanguay nous avons
conservé ce cadre que nous avons donné
aux joueurs ce soir l'équipe qui a gagné
c'est l'équipe des arbitres alors
maintenant à moi de devenir spectateur
et de vous voir arbitrer votre prochaine
rencontre
je vous souhaite d'être cet arbitre
facilitateur solide et juste de vos
équipes
merci